I think the queen had a really special
bond with all of her grandchildren but
particularly with Prince George and I
think that is because he is an heir to
the throne while the queen had this time
with Prince George she wanted to make
sure that she was there to be a great
grandmother of course she wanted to be
there to give him those early lessons in
preparing him for kingship which of
course he will learn from his
grandfather King Charles from his father
but there are lessons that only the
queen could have handed down and she was
very lucky that she was able to have
nine years with George to be able to do
that I think you know as the Prince of
Wales said in his statement he he felt
hugely grateful that his family got to
spend so much time with the queen I mean
Kate had 20 years to really get to know
the Monarch what a privilege as a future
Queen consort hugely important as well
but not just that the queen had a lot of
time with her great-grandchildren the
queen would Host this wonderful
sleepover at Balmoral in August and
invite all of the grandchildren and the
great grandchildren and she looked
forward to that weekend I think probably
more than any other it was always noisy
when Prince Philip was still alive he
made sure he wasn't around because there
were too many screaming children but the
queen absolutely loved it and I I think
it was massively important to her that
she got to spend that time with her
family the queen was the ultimate
working mum she didn't always have time
to be with her children so I think she
made sure that she treasured those
relationships with her grandchildren and
she was overjoyed to have it all over
again with their children her great
grandchildren
foreign